مواقع التواصل تسمح للاطفال بالانضمام
لخدماتها عند بلوغهم سن ال 13 من اعمارهم
لكن اصوات عده تطالب برفع الحد الادنى لسن
الاستخدام بالفعل هو جدال دائر مشاهدينا
في الولايات المتحده ما بين اطباء ومختصين
ومشرعين وحتى في الكونجرس الذي يبحث الان
قانونا لهذا الهدف يستشهد المؤيدون لرفع
السن بابحاث مختلفه توضح اضرار هذه
المنصات على المراهقين اهمها التاثير
السلبي على الصحه العقليه المؤيدون
يعتقدون ان صغار المراهقين ليسوا بالضجر
الكافي للتحكم بانفعالاتهم وتجنب ضغوطات
المقارنه مع اقرانهم وسوشل ميديا تدفعهم
دائما للتفاعل مع اشياء من المحتمل ان
يتجاهلها الكبار على العموم الكثيرون
اتفقوا على ان سن السادس عشر ربما يكون
الحد الادنى المناسب للانضمام الى تطبيقات
التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
خلينا نحكي تربويا وسلوكيا ماذا يعني انه
يكون طفل باقل عمره اقل من 13 عاما او 16
عاما عنده على مواقع التواصل حقيقه هي
خلينا نقول كارثه تربويه ممكن توصل لكارثه
تربويه تؤثر على نفسيه الطفل تؤثر على نمو
العقلي على نمو الجسدي وعلى نمو العاطفه
عندها مجموعه من التاثيرات اللي هي حقيقه
حساسه عند الفئه اللي هنا ممكن نقول
يافعين او مراهقين بهذه الفتره هويتهم
الرقميه مو موجوده هويتهم الشخصيه عم تنمو
عم يبحثوا عن من انا وفق هذا البحث ببلش
يشوفه طبعا بهذا الفتره كتير بتاثر
بالاقران فبيبلشوا يشوفوا مجموعه من
الترندات الترندات نماذج يعني مثل ما
بنشوف الترند هي شيء سريع بيطلع اليوم
بكره بيختفي بيطلع اليوم بكره بيختفي اللي
ممكن يكون اليوم شي موضه بكره حيصير ممل
وسخيف
التالي هون الهويه بتتعرض لتشويش وعم
نلاحظ انه في عنا خلل حقيقه بالنسيج
المجتمعي ممكن يصير مجموعه من الضغط
الانفعالي عند الطفل اللي بتبلش يشوف
الحياه بتوقعات مرتفعه بدا يشوف مثلا
ما بتعكس الواقع جزئيه تانيه هو عم يقول
في شب كان عم يحكي عن انه انا ما بتطلع
غير على الامور الايجابيه والفعاله وهاي
الامور هاد بنفس بحد ذاته عم يعمل ضغط
مجتمعي على الشباب بشوفوا مجموعه من
النماذج اللي هي عند الايجابيه المفرطه
اللي عندها نوع من انواع التظاهر او المال
الماديه المبالغ فيها بنلاقي بعض الاشخاص
اللي هن المشهورين على مواقع التواصل
الافتراضي بيلبسوا افضل لبس
احسن ماركات
افخم سيارات فبيطلع للنجاح بيشوفه بطريقه
كتير مبالغ فيها بيضغط هذا الشيء على
شعوره نفسي وبالتالي ممكن يسبب انتحار
ممكن يسبب قلق توتر عدم قبول للواقع
[موسيقى]